welcome everybody welcome to google
developers live you're on the chrome
channel i'm here today with chris wilson
developer advocate for chrome and sean
bennett a course architect at udacity
and myself
peter lopez a program manager for chrome
and we're here for the office the first
office hours
show
for the cs 256 udacity course that we
just launched last week
we had a great week where
close to 50 000 people already have
registered and signed up
and
we're going to bring you every week for
the next uh five weeks uh a series of
office hours where you can ask your
questions and if you want to ask your
questions you can go to
google developers live so that's
developers.google.com
live and find the weekly office hours
shows click on them and then there's a
moderator window that you can
ask your questions or vote for questions
and so we're gonna
dive into that in just a second um we
had a great week last week we had the
course launch on monday
we had a gdl show with sebastian thrun
so definitely check that out on the it's
also on the gdl calendar
and just wanted to
go over the first three lessons in this
office hours show
in future sessions we'll do
for example next week the same time we
will do lessons four and five then six
and seven eight and nine and then ten
through twelve
so we break it up in that way and we
hopefully you can um go through a couple
of those lessons
and then ask your questions here and
we're we're here for five weeks uh to
follow along so
without further ado this the first two
lessons were pretty quick uh i think the
first one was sort of the syllabus
second one was the mobile developer
tools um a quick intro on how you can
debug on mobile it's pretty important
and there's a lot of great stuff in
there now that that you know even a
couple of months ago wasn't there we
actually held off on that lesson
to to have things landing in chrome for
that purpose things weren't quite
finished
now uh the third lesson is really where
we get into the the meat of the project
the viewport and ux
uh so a couple of things about that
lesson first one is one of my favorite
scenes in there if you haven't seen it
the the door slam is what we call it
we spent quite a bit of time in the in
the udacity study studio uh slamming
doors in fact a lot of people started
walking by and saying what's going on
here i was just standing there slamming
the door and someone's like are you okay
right what are you doing
you have the perfect double door
that was great yeah that was that was a
perfect thing yeah so the door slam of
course meaning uh you go on a site and
it blocks you from going any further on
the web experience and tries to have you
go on the mobile only native experience
and in many cases that's not really
necessary so in large part that's what
this course is about but the the
viewport lesson that the third lesson
is also one of the ones that has been
probably re-recorded the most i think i
did spend the most time re-recording
sections of that one there was at least
four yeah so so why why was that why did
you have to go back in so well i mean
this kind of comes out in the the lesson
but viewport has kind of a long and
storied history i mean it started when
um when apple introduced the first
iphone and they had to figure out how to
get the real web experience kind of
shoehorned onto this browser
on a very small screen but then they
also wanted to recognize that there were
going to be people who are going to
start writing for this device like they
were going to make it work well on the
device they needed some controls on that
kind of shoehorn as well
and the challenge was it was uncharted
territory at that point and they what
they came up with was
kind of good
but it had some wacky little bits to it
i think and it continues to have some
wacky bits
even today and you know i mentioned in
the lesson
there's a couple of gotchas about
developing for iphones specifically and
there's not a lot of good guidance out
there about why exactly you need to do
this or that like why you need that
initial scale 1.0 or when you might want
to use your user scalable no
and um
i had to to dig all of this up and
figure it out and and i thought i'd
figured it out and then i would discover
that no that wasn't actually how it
worked and i think the the last one that
i had to record for
was when i discovered that um on the
iphone
when you rotate between
landscape and portrait it keeps the same
or it scales up the font size it doesn't
actually change the viewport in that
case it just scales up the font size
which if you have you know if you
haven't explicitly gone and reset all of
your css and set your font size in a
fixed size
um it will look like it's reformatting
it yeah okay right and i thought that it
was for a while until finally i was
playing with different you know
different content on the page and
realized that in fact no it's not
reformatting it and it's different
between the iphone and the ipad in that
case too it's not just an ios switch it
actually i don't know if it wasn't this
special different size or something
between different versions of ios yeah
absolutely
they have changed it between six and
seven and that was during the course i
kept uh one of my devices on ios 6 for a
long time specifically just to test that
yeah
and um
then you know had borrowed someone
else's iphone to see what ios7 did so
yeah i remember during the course
development we had a lot of these like
oh does anyone have a phone with this in
this configuration yeah
something's not easy we were borrowing a
lot of random phones right around the
office yes
yeah i finally even had like five or six
so i finally got to stop carrying around
the pile of mobile devices in my
backpack everywhere i go yeah i only you
know i carry a few but not not five
different phones yeah exactly exactly
well one of the other ones we had was
the mobile dev tools when you turn on
the developer mode on
the um on the androids right yeah it's
really weird so you want to go into the
steps and then you have to press a
certain the build number seven times um
doing that
is only a one-time thing i think you
have to reset your whole phone yeah you
have to you have to factory reset right
yeah and wipe everything on it to get
rid of that we only had one shot at that
video
yeah
it didn't work it didn't work right
actually i think we had to use my phone
because you'd already done that that's
our phone and then realized that we
couldn't do it again yeah i tried to tap
it seven times again that didn't work
that was actually um
and that's part of the one of the more
frustrating things i think is that that
process is a little bit different
on every single device and that's
something that
i think our students have come across
too yeah there have been comments in the
forum about that it's different on
different devices and um you know
different versions of android did
something subtly different there and
finding all that is a little bit
problematic i think probably something
we should do is is kind of have some of
that commentary in the instructor now
it's down the bottom that we should
compile
um the the students have actually done a
great job of starting that off already
nice
great so
we've got a couple of questions i think
around 10 or so
that we have on the dory so again if you
have questions
for
for the next office hour session go to
developers.google.com live and then find
the there's a calendar there you can
find the
uh the office hour sessions
if you click to the page through to the
page then you can find a moderator
window at the bottom
where you can ask your questions you can
vote for questions so that's a great way
to to get in so
again next week same time we'll be
covering four and five and then
the following three weeks after that
we'll do more office hours so first
question is from epocholus from toronto
uh i want to develop a mobile web app
and what tools ides
languages frameworks like amber dart
backbone and so on would you recommend
and i think maybe
would help to start with
you know why we didn't cover those
specifically in the course yeah yeah i
mean i i tend to really like to
understand the techniques that i'm using
at a very low level so understand why
not not just hey put this viewport
boilerplate at the top of all your pages
because it's magic and it just makes
everything better but understand exactly
what it does and how it works and what
it's going to do which is why we didn't
really focus on using a lot of
frameworks particularly because many of
the frameworks they just bake all of
that in they've already done a lot of
the responsive design for you even and
as long as you you know stick with
exactly their sets of elements in your
pages
it'll all reflow but you may forget and
you may not realize that you've just
locked it to a particular size when you
do that
so we didn't really want to focus on a
particular
a particular framework because of that
and
in terms of ides you know most of this
really again we're getting down to the
basics of
um what the actual html and css and
javascript is in the page so we didn't
want to lock into a particular id you
will notice of course we use sublime
but really didn't do much other than
than syntax highlighting yeah i mean any
id should work just fine any ide should
work there's a lot of cloud ids out now
as well so which i think is is kind of
cool because you can take things with
you a little more easily
as far as languages go obviously html
css and javascript on the client are are
great we're starting to see
a fairly large uptake in dart usage as
well in large scale mobile applications
um obviously i wouldn't start out by
trying to learn uh trying to learn that
just in order to build any mobile web
web app um and then on the server side
of course i think the the sky is the
limit yeah a lot of different different
things to do there
yeah and i think the other thing is like
you don't want to just
package all those things in there for
maybe
and you have to really think about are
you what are you using these libraries
for
do you really need it because on mobile
you're going to have
additional downloads for those libraries
it's going to just take more time i mean
each single additional request that you
make is
going to potentially be a big deal right
i mean yeah that's one of the the
biggest challenges that i have is people
will send me code all the time and say
hey could you you know help me figure
out what's going on here
and i have to dig through three
different frameworks and figure out how
they're interacting with you with each
other which isn't always what they're
designed to do either
and as sean said you know on mobile
particularly every single download adds
to the weight of your application coming
across that wire yeah i mean you can you
can mitigate some of that by you know
using uh front-end um library frameworks
like bauer or something like that to
kind of minimize and sure and
concatenate all of this stuff
but i mean it still has to come down the
wire at some point or another right and
a lot of people make the mistake of not
doing things like that and just for
example including it from another um
from like the
library's website or something and
that's that's just another network
request that you have to worry about
they might find that in the sample code
or something right yeah actually that
sort of brings i guess the next question
from
rockstar
in pune
what is mobile optimization technique so
it's a probably a little bit of a vague
question but i think we just talked
about some of these things right we have
a
performance lesson
later in the course
and
one of the the main things that we
really wanted to do in this course was
to build in
performance really
from the start so
like there's mobile first and there's
performance first um
perf matters
everything first first
yeah exactly
um and it was interesting because we
wanted to really actually start out with
the performance we did absolutely yeah
our original idea was like right let's
start with performance yeah but then you
can't
if you haven't done anything yet right
like it's kind of hard to jump into that
without any other information
when you haven't done anything right
very fast
but yeah so the performance lesson talks
in more detail about the different kinds
of things you might consider
one of those would be those frameworks
or the different libraries like you know
trying to really figure out what you
need
minimizing things i would say
rockstar
follow us follow along and maybe if you
have some more very specific questions
uh post them in the
when we get to that lesson
and then we'll cover those in more
detail one more one more thing that we
said uh in that lesson i believe was if
you are using those frameworks any of
those frameworks be sure to check and
see if there are faster optimized
versions of those that are specific to
mobile or at least are heavily mobile
optimized some of the frameworks
particularly the older ones aren't
really optimized for mobile yet but
there are
alternatives to them like you know zepto
for for jquery and things like that yeah
or if they're just light versions of
those like like regular light or
something like that um that it's
probably not mobile optimized but it's
still quite a bit smaller and faster so
yeah
another thing that you might want to do
um is just follow along with you know we
mentioned
perf matters but yeah you might want to
look at that on your social network of
choice because there's a lot of great
stuff there yeah and there's also um
yeah that's a great point and also html5
rocks now has a whole mobile section and
there's a lot of great articles coming
out especially last quarter
a ton of great new content so definitely
check that out uh it's a great way of
learning more about that yeah so uh
aniket goley from mumbai um how do i
start a mobile web development project
i have the idea in mind like starting
from app design or database design so i
would um probably not start with the
database design i would start probably
more at the
what the user experience
might be and your idea for the app and
you have any
yeah yeah i would say so i mean if you
start from the
how you're storing the data right that
really can like that locks you in it's
hard to change that after the fact right
really hard to change that you do have
to be very careful about you know fully
designing your database and then
then trying to go back later and
changing it although i will say i think
it it depends on the app rather heavily
too i mean if what you're really
trying to do is you know a contacts list
or something
it kind of makes sense to start from at
least an initial database design yeah
don't go you know populating all the
massive data in your back end or
anything right until you've you've done
a little bit of the front end too
but if you have a true mvc model um in
your application that makes it easier to
do those things separately too to have
have those components separate yeah
perfect perfect
a question from macy from la
i want more practice can you give up
more projects on top of the exercise and
what should the mobile web dev learning
path be when there's so many languages
to learn html css javascript php python
which can't be all learned at once and
that's true yeah absolutely
well the good news on learning more
stuff is there is a whole
you know web and cs
path at udacity there's also that we are
still trying to build out and slowly as
maybe progress if you tuned in last week
sebastian has big plans yeah yeah for 60
courses how are you doing in these
safety courses have you there there's
been some sleep you know okay
it's been good 20 minutes here there
cut that out
right
it is kind of overwhelming like if you
want to learn all this stuff it's
exciting um i mean i guess the best
thing would be yeah start
from you know start taking the paths
that exist there and it's not just on
udacity but you know you can there's
many other
things for example the
the javascript the discover dev tools
code school courses
it's really good it's quick you can
learn just a lot of stuff and in the
process you learn to use the dev tools
but also you learn more about how web
pages are put together
um
so
more projects yeah i think one of the
things i would suggest is
yep
try to build your own app right like try
to come up with a concept that you're
excited about something that you want to
do or have been trying to do for a while
and try it out and that's probably like
learn by doing there's there's a bit of
a tough balance here between you know
people who already have an idea like
that that they want to build and trying
to create projects that just anyone can
build because i mean you want someone to
be building projects they care about
they're going to learn more they're
going to learn better if they're doing
that yeah i mean when we when we started
developing this course there was a lot
yeah we went back and forth on what
exactly we would center the course
around right repeatedly i mean yeah we
had this whole chart of well we could do
this app or this app or this app yeah
and we finally ended up with the
conference app because it was one that
not only
um did we think it hit most of the
lessons like we could could sort of
address most of the lessons in it but it
was something we cared about and
something that we actually did want to
see this kind of application
we'd had a need for it before hopefully
we'll we'll have a need for it in the
future too
and uh we can can keep working on it i i
do think that the biggest thing i would
say about trying not to learn everything
at once is um
you know you don't need to do all
all facets of an application at the same
time you can
fake up the back end you know fake up
the data store for a while and don't
don't dive into php and python at the
same time that you're trying to
you know figure out your advanced css
and do the front end
i know certainly when i look at at where
i am on the learning curve
i'm in a very different place in html
css and javascript than i am in php and
python
i'm much more of a frontend person than
a back-end person if i was trying to do
a heavy-duty back-end database i'd find
somebody else to work with on it yeah
well
that's actually a really good right yeah
a really good point so finding a buddy
or
someone to work with is really great and
one good way to find that is um by going
on meetup yeah there's actually quite a
few meetups for example i run the san
francisco html5 meetup and we've done
study groups like that in the past
just um jams which is right right
yeah but there are actually meetups
happening right now
the for example in the bay area there's
a meet up that is following this course
every sunday they're getting together in
person and then you can learn a lot
because some people come from a database
background or another background then
you can just kind of help each other and
this helps also in figuring out projects
to do because you might not have an idea
but
it's a lot easier to be creative and and
have an idea like that when you can just
bounce things off of each other right
right
it's hard to just come up with your own
thing
completely in a vacuum yeah
and you know if if there isn't one in
your area start one yeah i know yeah
there's lots of people out there who
want to learn the same things that you
do
yeah yeah right right that's great
um so a question about some technical
difficulties there's a problem with
problem set three uh not getting credit
despite completing the task
so something
yeah so um i i i responded to this a
little bit
uh earlier in the week um saying that
you know if it if there continue to be
problems with these then we'd probably
um replace with these with some some
videos and such because most of these
problem sets are fairly open-ended okay
going back to the you know build
something yourself
um we i mean we really want people to
think about how these lessons impact
their own projects either stuff they've
already built or stuff that they want to
build and you know discuss that with
other people um discussing these things
and these ideas on the forums or on a
meetup or
or wherever is a very important part of
this so um so yeah we might just replace
this with something kind of open-ended
that i think fits the spirit of the
course a bit more anyway yeah okay that
was from sam in brussels so belgium so
um
all right so we'll look into that
uh how many of these apps
from
yankee in india how many of these apps
can work offline
does making mobile apps include making
of games and
i need to know what types of apps we're
going to make in this course so
well
there are a couple of questions in there
yeah yeah but the app that fits with
this course is the the conference app
that we uh we reference quite a bit yeah
to make an app that literally covers
every detail of um
every lesson would be a little bit of a
contrived example
but we tried as chris mentioned earlier
like to get something to try
but there were certainly some parts
right when we looked at it and just said
you know this is kind of weird putting
not much yeah you know putting the
device motion api into the conference
app was a little strange i mean we used
local storage i believe in the
conference app but i don't think we do
much
we have an app cache but it's not um
yeah i mean
actually the the biggest thing that we
don't do right now in this course um
with that app is
we don't actually do the data model the
way you would need to um you would need
to have a local storage database or or
you know index database most likely of
course yeah um
that is synchronizing the data with an
external server and figuring out a good
policy for
when and how to update that and and
upgrade the database which has a lot of
back-end component to it which is why we
didn't actually do it
in the course right now um we're pulling
in all that data through json and you
know just loading it up
and we did do an app caches the the
offline lesson actually walks you
through how to do
an app cache for
just the conference application and the
data that it currently uses
so
the app that we're doing does do do
offline you know does work offline i
think um
when i think of what you can do on
mobile
what you should do on mobile with the
web platform
i'd say you should always try to make
your apps work offline um because it's
not always offline yeah
it's i mean i walk around my office and
we don't get great cell reception on my
carrier in the middle of my office it's
actually okay because i'm on wi-fi most
of the time but there's still that
latency of wi-fi that you can radically
improve even with app cache and it's
it's um
much maligned capabilities and
syntax it still is a powerful tool
for getting your apps to work offline
um
on the game's question you know we don't
actually
really dive into games in this course at
all some of the apis um like you know
device motion and things like that you
will
think about it and say wow this you know
this could be really cool and then
some of our examples even i think were
little mini games um
but uh
you know there is a i'll i'll play colt
for a second here i should shave my head
or something yeah
there's a great course
you should check it out cs255 on udacity
uh that colt did on um on making html
games
and uh a lot of that applies as well on
mobile
and i think a lot too like the
performance lesson especially yes
definitely applies to games as well yeah
um more than anything i mean
you need to get that performance
characteristic down if you really want
to make a game yes i mean if you're
interested in making games on mobile
using the web platform i think i would
look very carefully at performance
anything you can learn about performance
is going to help you um
any the
the unfortunately um still in progress
responsive images solution is going to
be pretty critical because on mobile
devices you really do want it to be kind
of native device resolution because
it'll look beautiful right um
and at the same time you have to be
careful not to dump tons and tons of
data right so offline's also very
important so like i think those um those
three
lessons are going to end up being
incredibly critical yeah i actually i
was messing around with a um
webgl game
just
this past weekend i think and i was
really excited to see you know it
obviously loaded just so much data
because it was a full 3d game in the
browser and it asked if i could um if it
could store data offline and everything
for me and a little pop-up came up and
said please click yes on that because
then the next time that you load this
it'll actually go much faster and then i
went ahead and reloaded it it was about
you know a few seconds to
load all the data at that point i was
like this is awesome
nice
all right so we have a linguistics
student from tennessee
if i don't have an android if i don't
have any android equipment at all
then
and just a windows computer with chrome
can i find a way to start the lesson so
yes
a lot of the information you can go
through just in the browser yeah um i
mean technically all of it you can you
can do the entire course without any
mobile device
the only problem is there are parts of
the course that you won't be able to
actually
see in practice see like viewport is a
good example where um you know viewport
does something very dramatic on mobile
it's very critical for you to use
viewports on mobile and at the same time
they take no effect whatsoever on the
desktop browser right so so it's not
going to change anything in the desktop
yeah so you can so basically take it all
but but following along and seeing these
things for yourself is going to be much
harder and once you get to the point of
of really trying to develop mobile web
applications the performance lessons
even i mean you're going to need to do
this on a mobile device you can still
get going without a mobile device and
you can simulate simulate some of the
issues that you'll run into with things
like browser stack but i mean yeah
you're
there's really no
substitute for having a device there to
actually
experiment with and actually if you go
into the developer tools in the
emulation tools you can actually turn on
some of those features too mobile
overrides yeah do the overrides yeah
that's true it's not as good as actually
pairing the phone up but it does still
give you some of the some of the
same type of issues especially the
layout type of issues
so we have another question from adriano
in egypt i love how we have students
from
all over the world asking questions
which is just great and um if you're
watching then um
thanks for staying up late
so the question is is phonegap useful
for mobile web development okay
good question yeah um i think uh quite
useful for packaging up
applications
so that you can sell them in the web in
the different stores right yeah
absolutely um for example for
chrome apps yeah that's sort of
currently the
the actual solution for getting those
apps in other web stores right chrome
apps you can build in html5
and then
yeah distribute through the chrome web
store we want to hit the other stores
and it's a lot of it this is all about
monetization then
this is a great uh yeah great product
i think the open source version is
cordova well yeah so the name has
changed right sort of interchangeable
kind of apache cordova yeah i mean
keeping keep in mind that that isn't
going to replace the lessons you need to
learn from this course yeah like it's a
a packaging mechanism to get it into
more more areas to get in into a bunch
of app stores you still have to build
the application yeah and that's yeah it
is it's also useful if um you want to
access device apis that haven't yet
landed in uh
like the html5 spec yet correct right so
if you wanted to do for example push
notifications it's a great way to do
that while still writing essentially a
web app yeah exactly and just adding
functionality until we get that in the
web which yeah hopefully we will pretty
soon
being worked on yeah
but it takes a little while right cool
there's question from nab in nepal i try
to test my mobile web app on both ways
on emulator arm as well as on chrome
canary but i feel it is very difficult
to work with them due to speed is there
any other way to test my site quickly
i'm not familiar with what emulator arm
is no oh running uh
the android emulator oh is that what was
the android emulator is uh
painfully slow to run the browser on
at least the last time i did it which
was i'll grant you a while ago
also on chrome canary
so i mean some issues with canary maybe
or not yeah i mean they're it's still
pretty it's canary yeah it's canary um
so it's used at your own risk right yeah
um you can also try doing this on chrome
stable
uh are not chrome stable chrome beta
yeah um and i think all the emulation
features are there in beta right i mean
there are some great features in canary
right that if you want the really the
latest and greatest cutting edge but
sometimes
things break it's going to be yeah a
little button
it gets rebuilt every day so
so um but in terms of speed i don't
think
i don't think they're currently at least
i haven't noticed any issues i'd love to
especially if you're running it locally
there shouldn't really be any issue i
mean just as as a way to try things out
i think
if you're on your site on localhost in
canada i think
really there shouldn't be a problem if
maybe there's a connectivity problem
there yeah that could be
not great bandwidth or something like
that so
hopefully try that out running things
locally can area i think it should be
okay now yeah i mean and and if you have
more specific questions
um i'd love for you to post post it
again like in later lessons especially
the performance lesson if that's if it's
an issue with performance like
uh more generally as well right right
yeah
so there's a question from donny
will the course include an introduction
to the google closure compiler
for optimizing performance
uh the short answer is no no the course
is already
it's already finished so it doesn't have
that uh there's probably some
information on that
out there yeah i mean using the google
closure compiler i think there's some
fairly reasonable docs on that um we
didn't really get into
you know any kind of
optimization or minification libraries
or anything like that
um
but again they're
their resources closure is a great tool
yeah we actually use there's so many
great tools out there yeah
i think that that's part of the reason
why we didn't talk about a lot of those
too is because there are a lot of
different great tools and as if we
talked about one we'd just get a bunch
of people saying well why didn't you
talk about you know
x library that's my favorite um
and
once you learn a few of them then yeah
they're all fairly
fairly similar we could probably start a
few religious wars
yeah i think the latest one is grunt
first gulp
oh i'm gonna move over here
yeah
okay
so oscar in mexico he's asking are we
going to be using eclipse in the android
sdk to develop apps or mainly html5 css
javascript so okay quick answer there
oscar
no it's really just
html5 css and javascript for this course
really that's all you need for building
great web experiences yeah
simple um
next question from the netherlands my
home country
should have moved this up a little bit
of course
if you use other than html such as
python and you test on localhost and use
port forwarding to the tablet
how do you use google chrome tools
because you cannot save the changes
you should be able to save changes there
is not anywhere not if you're back if
you're using port forwarding oh right
okay
you can do it you can do it locally on
the desktop browser but you can't port
those changes back um
i see right yeah stay tuned i think is
the only answer there i don't know how
soon that's gonna get resolved
personally what i would likely do is i
would keep the um
i would keep the the mobile debugging
session open and open a desktop
debugging session on the same set and
make the changes at the same time right
yeah um it's not a great solution you're
still making the changes twice
so it's definitely this is a good point
i'll float it past some of the
the dev tools folks and see
if it's on their radar they may actually
have a solution
yeah they very well might devtools was
another area where during while we were
developing the course every day it felt
like something changed and mostly it's
better yeah it's like well this doesn't
work work oh well that change is coming
it's you know look at it tomorrow
there was one of them i can't remember
what it was but i like hit some bug
and
literally what i had to do was close the
browser and restart it because the the
change it had not only gotten detected
and fixed by the dev tools team it had
already rolled out in canary
and i just hadn't reset it relaunched my
browser yeah yeah yeah it's very fast
moving uh so uh so we'll look into that
a little bit see if there's a better
answer i'll follow up in the in the
moderator thread
um so
jesus from nadar
to test all the websites i normally use
firefox and chrome responsive view for
testing in tablets and mobile
but some people use ripple
and they're little difference in
rendering is there any difference
between ripple and responsive views like
in the browser um
if you're familiar with it i'm not i'm
not familiar with it so
okay
we're not familiar with that so
um
let us figure that out and we'll post an
answer in the in the forum and sam
samski's from san francisco uh where can
i get information for the sunday study
group that i just mentioned it's great
to see all these live
questions something popping up here
so i will post a link to that it's a
it's a new meetup it's in
i think in the
it's not in san francisco it's in
i think the south bay uh i'll post a
link sam to
that exact group and i think it's great
i
i was actually asked to come over there
on sunday um i can't make it at that
particular time but they're going to be
hosting a several of those and be great
so i'll post a link in the in the thread
it's on it's on meetup maybe you can do
a search for it but i'll post a link to
it so
uh
neo
max geek
is that the real name okay from from
cairo
what is the best way to validate my game
data such as a score or player profile
if i'm dealing with a back end
all right that gets a little bit off
track from the
from you know the first three lessons
i think um
maybe the best thing there is to check
out some of the
well i guess the cs255 this doesn't
really deal with that so
um i guess it depends on what he means
by
um by validate does he mean like make
sure that the player hasn't switched the
data and then you know
change things around i think
what
colt has talked about this a few
different times and i think probably
just
for a quick answer
you want to make sure that the server is
keeping track of all everything that's
going on like each step of
what's going on in whatever the game is
so that
if the player tries to send erroneous
data then the server can say well that
doesn't make sense based on everything
else i know right so you have the uh the
server continuously updating the game
state as well as the the player so that
the the server can
serve as a
as a shake your finger at them kind of
thing
all right so there's a question from
atlanta from emelia
i'm new to web development i'm
struggling to understand javascript
along with this course what tools or
methods would you recommend for learning
and understanding javascript so
um any uh i would say there i mean there
are a number of good resources out there
um there's some good resource resources
at codecademy and code school right now
um
just looking through um
some of the like uh smaller snippet type
websites like codepen
it's often like they're normally fairly
descriptive and and what they do i'd
also suggest looking through that um
great great books as well yeah and
there's some great books eloquent
javascript for people that still read
books yeah yeah that's a fantastic
eloquent javascript that's really well
that's really good
if you want to
learn some of the ways that javascript
can
bite you i'd also recommend javascript
the good parts
it's a fantastic book and it really
quickly gets you past a lot of the
hiccups and headaches that uh
that can happen so i'd recommend that as
well hairiness of javascript right yeah
um that's a as far as i'm concerned is a
must must read yeah i think both that
and eloquent javascript okay yeah cool
um using so a question from tbuvan in
hyderabad
using a separate html and css
will this be enough to build an awesome
responsive web app or is it good to go
with media queries you didn't say
awesome
well i
so you want to build an awesome app
he didn't say he wanted to build an
asana mediocre
uh i think uh you know viewport is is
kind of the foundation like that's where
you have to start um it's by design that
the very next lesson leads into media
queries though because you really
you can build an adaptive application
you know you can build an adaptive
layout where you can stretch things
right yeah um
and you can you know it kind of starts
with well
make it so that the browser understands
exactly how big your screen really is
and that's viewport and then there's the
you know tools for doing adaptive layout
where if the window is bigger or smaller
you know if the viewport is bigger or
smaller how do we draw into that you
know how do we stretch across that
rather than having fixed sizes for
everything
and then the final step is you know
there actually is a fairly sizable
difference between
developing for you know my my cell phone
that's buried in my pocket somewhere and
and you know my two different sizes of
tablets and my my desktop and laptop
screens um and for that you really do
need to use media queries i mean you
need to have that adaptiveness of
well if i have this much room to render
into i would do something very different
than if i have this much yeah basically
whenever whenever you have to go to a
fundamentally different layout scheme
it's really you need to use media
queries yeah
cool so a question from renov could we
have a brief session on admob monetizing
app and publishing it on the play store
so renov
not really part of this course one of
the things i would suggest is go on
google developers live that what you're
on right now
developers.google.com
live and there's a big calendar there
that has
gdl or google developer live sessions
from all kinds of products you find
stuff about android you find stuff about
admob for example
i can also check with some of the people
in internally to see what they would
recommend maybe
an intro to that so i'll post that in
the moderator so
and then we've got our final question
from
uganda
i'm new to mobile app development and
android but i've totally failed to run
my first app in the emulator even after
doing everything right as i instructed
and
can we have some insistence so
you don't really need
to run
things in the emulator
not not for this course at least
yeah running them in in the android
emulator is pretty challenging right now
because it is
it's going through so many steps of
emulation there that it's kind of right
i mean it's running chrome on top of the
emulator and that makes it kind of
challenging and very slow
that way but since you brought it up yes
yes
pretty slow yeah yeah actually there's a
another question that just
popped up what is the best way
to test mobile web on different devices
that has
uh on the on the market let's see
you know having all the devices very
hard oh i see so yeah question that's
like how do you keep up with the
plethora of devices right yeah
from nab and nepal
so
um
having a bunch of different devices is
hard especially like if you don't have
just the the money to do that or you
know
even just keeping them all up to date
right is kind of a pain running yeah if
you if you need to run on ios 6 and ios
7 you need two different devices and you
know all these other yeah maintaining a
device lab
is surprisingly really difficult yeah as
well as expensive yeah as well but there
are some open right like free device
labs in different countries i'm not sure
anything close to nab in nepal but i
know for example in germany and england
there's these device labs where people
can go in and do that so maybe something
like that yeah yeah and i mean if you
don't if you can't get to an actual
device lab then then again you know
browser stack and similar
um
similar services
are
i mean it's not quite it's not quite the
same thing it's not quite the same thing
but it is a big help i think the the
best advice i could
i could give is
make sure you do
as you're becoming a real you know
professional level web developer on
mobile you need to have at least a few
different different devices and
different is a critical piece there you
know don't just get
two phones that are almost identical you
know get a phone and a tablet and get an
ios device and an android device and you
know like branch out as much as possible
yeah
i think uh ppk he would he mentioned
once like every couple of months you
just need to invest in a new phone or
something like that yeah
he's a little bit more hardcore i know i
know i'm not good it's a bit extreme
and i would expect everyone needs to be
there are also some
some things that you can test against
then uh much more easily like if you
know they're the same version of the
browser that are running right yeah on
these different devices you can actually
go in in the desktop browser and change
the
um you know change what override you're
using right tell it okay now act like
you're a
you know whatever device
yeah and that will usually cover the
differences between like a nexus 7
tablet and a nexus 4 phone
yeah yeah overrides in the dev tools
there's also the opera mobile emulator
yeah things like that are a good way to
substitute um
actually we're getting more questions in
as we speak that was the last question
but now we have four more
how can we use this course to help build
a portfolio which will show a range of
new topics covered
can we have more examples to build on
so we're unlikely to add
new sample apps but those apps you can
actually just grab them modify them
any way you want you can
you know kick off a few of your own
projects any other yeah i think a lot of
this is figuring out something you want
to build that exemplifies
you know that lesson for example
exemplifies touch you know maybe a
drawing board app or something like that
something relatively simple but still
showcases okay i i know how to use the
touch or the pointer apis to do this
right
you know building something small that
you come up with is a really good way to
go there um
yeah i
i mean for myself uh one of the things
that i did was i actually took you know
people who know me know i'm really
passionate about audio things
i took a bunch of my audio demos and i
used them as examples and and one of
them actually i used in the course as an
example but i went through and this
actually taught me a lot about using you
know using viewport using flexbox to do
to do layout um and making it work
across different devices and portrait
and landscape like you know i have my
little audio recorder app right that i i
put in you know the ability to flip from
portrait to landscape and have it
reformat the ap the uh the ui completely
when you do that and some of it some of
it i remember
it didn't take very much time no no it
didn't take so long that much and
because it was an application that i was
already
kind of jazzed about you know something
that i found exciting to to work on
it was really easy for me to learn that
way exactly
one thing i i
you know if you don't have any ideas one
thing i might suggest for like the first
few lessons where we're really talking
about design and layout and things like
that just you know go to one of your
favorite websites or web apps or
something and figure out you know well
how did they do that yeah you know open
up open up the dev tools and look
through things it's sometimes a little
bit hard to do but you know or go to one
of your favorite websites that doesn't
really work well yeah well and figure
out how you would make it work yeah i
mean i mean i did that with a news
reader that
that i use that doesn't work on mobile
at all and it just annoyed me
newsreader actually was one of the
candidates for our app i remember and
also um in the intro we used google news
as an example of an app that does adapt
and that's one of the things you can can
look through and think about is you know
how would i take this ui that works
maybe really well on a desktop or a
laptop
and how would i make that work well on a
tablet how would i make it work well on
a phone and i think that you'll get a
lot of ideas from that
yeah cool cool so that was from qj and
palestine so a question from ankur in
india till now i know that we can make
android apps with java or in python
using kivy
which language do you use and which
mobile platforms do these apps support
so that's simple it's basically all html
javascript and css that we're using in
this course to build these web apps
and then the final question from ali
in chicago
in this course will you plan to cover
tools like yeoman bauer and grunt also
will you plan to use any test frameworks
in the course
yeah your favorite topic sean
so no we don't we don't specifically
cover yeoman bauer and grunt
you can look at those on the repo for
the conference app um yeah interesting
that the conference app actually does
use yet but we don't really go into
those because they're fairly tool
specific and it's it we felt it would
detract from a lot of the other um
lessons that we wanted to teach and
um we actually i think near the end we
we talked about maybe doing like build
tools and something like that at some
point and at that point we had already
done
like you know we started with like six
lessons like oh we should split these
two up or we should add this and then
you know all of a sudden we're at 12
lessons and it's getting
monstrous we were like no no more we're
stopping here
um that said though tools like yeoman
and bauer and grunt are
you know really fantastic they do a lot
of this um build stuff for you and
automate some of that um
it can be a little bit of a headache at
points
especially if you're not quite familiar
with those tools um
but it does do a lot of really nice
stuff for you honestly uh using app
cache and offline with with build tools
can be kind of a pain too unless you set
it up to automate it and just keep
touching your
uh your app cache and and changing it
not just touching it but changing the
app cache file right absolutely write a
random string to it
yes
one wow
rolling in i thought we were done but
okay there's a couple more so we have a
couple more minutes uh one from dilvon
from my favorite city in the world
lisbon portugal
the future of mobile development is it
html5
well oh
we're a bit biased who
might be slightly biased asking the
wrong people here
we think so
but there are
lots of opportunities right i mean i i
really believe in the web as a platform
just because it's you know it's one
platform that everyone can run that's
not you know
that you don't have to build different
codebase completely different code bases
for everything you know there are tricks
and tweaks and you know it's not all
roses and unicorns yes but
i mean it's a lot closer than having to
maintain two entirely separate code
bases it is i mean my you know i've been
at this a long time and my background
was was in
the days when it was whether you had a
windows app or a mac app yeah and
at the time
you know most major applications
particularly in like media areas that i
was interested in
they didn't build all the time on both
platforms because it was very hard they
had totally different api sets
different languages effectively because
you know you were objective cn1 and c
plus plus one and the other
and
um you know
even where we are today with native
mobile uh mode
native mobile platforms um it's still
usually a pretty significant change
between those two so you really are
developing two separate applications and
then again on the desktop space i look
at the things that i use today
very little of what i use on the desktop
is an app yeah it's a web app like i
mean you go look at my desktop machines
at home and
and even this machine it's like it's
probably running sublime and
a browser a couple of browsers
at any given time and that's all it's
really running because so much of what i
do
is in the web platform and i think that
it's natural that that move to mobile as
well
there are definitely some rough areas
there right now there are definitely um
parts of the user experience that end to
end are not as smooth
and i think those are getting you know
those are getting worked on by all the
vendors by all the mobile vendors
and obviously a native platform always
can innovate a little faster as well and
that's you know kind of a challenge but
i think there's so much you can do with
the web platform today on mobile and
that's where i really hope that people
look at
the device access lesson for example
and really think about what you could do
with this platform because there is a
ton of stuff in there and you can build
so many compelling applications
and having it you know just in the palm
of your hand is a very powerful thing
yeah
right
all right um
one question from benjamin in atlanta
was about
net beans i think one of the maybe
confusing parts has been
that you really don't need the the
typical android stack for development
here it's really just web development
and
keeps it very simple your html editor
you need your html css and javascript
use chrome dev tools um
any other dev tools as well but there
are some really nice features in
in developer tools in chrome that can
help you develop and debug that very
quickly
so that's what i would recommend
and then many of which are very new by
the way that's why we say that it's not
that we're saying other browsers don't
have good developer tools because they
certainly do it's just you know the the
devtools team on chrome has been doing
some awesome work lately and it's just
so compelling you know it's so neat to
be able to just plug it in and
i know just you know set breakpoints and
watch your performance profiles on the
actual mobile device yeah that's really
cool i mean my my basic setup is you
know a terminal chrome dev tools and
probably brackets because it's got a
pretty sweet interface and one of these
and one of those
and a usb cable
that's all you need
very good very good so
with that oh there's one final question
from tbuvan in hyderabad and then we're
gonna close it up coming yeah i know
this is this is great and just where
they're coming from it's just incredible
so um
is there any server side language to be
used in mobile development other than
java and php i heard about node.js and
which is faster so yeah node.js is
definitely it's a great way to
develop on the server side because
you're effectively writing in javascript
yeah well i mean that's true it's it's
not that node.js is faster running on
the server
um
it's not that your code running in the
browser is going to be faster the back
end is in node.js it's really that
if you're already learning javascript or
if that's you know if you're sitting
there and you've learned javascript to
do the front end of your application on
the client and you need to start
building the back end and your choices
are use node.js which is javascript or
you know go learn php or python or java
or whatever from the ground up
probably a little easier to get started
with node.js i think node.js is
fantastic yeah yeah i'm certainly i'm a
big fan
it's not the only
solution mean we we use python
at udacity and it's yeah yeah we really
like it node.js is also something
fantastic um it really depends on what
what you want to learn and what fits you
i mean back-end languages
are relatively interchangeable depending
on what you want to do well hopefully
that that wire you know there's yeah
there's the yeah what you get over the
wire and you can change each part of
that independently right yeah
well great so that wraps it up um i want
to thank everybody that asked questions
some great questions in there and they
just kept on coming i want to thank
everybody for uh tuning in and this
session will be recorded so we'll make
the recordings available they will
actually be available at the same exact
url
next week we'll be covering episode or
lessons four and five from the course
so again you can go to
developers.google.com
live
and find next week's uh session and
click on it go to the bottom of the page
and start asking your questions you can
yeah it's not too late just vote on
questions too yeah right the voting has
been great because it keeps actually
yeah it pumps questions up so yeah you
know we
right so make sure we get the highest
voters
yeah exactly so so anyway with that i'd
like to uh wrap it up thanks sean
thank you for coming and um see you next
week thanks a lot thanks bye